there is some real debate going on i'm
quite excited for this
so if you didn't hear the first
especially the trip from france to spain
um yeah okay so if you're here
do you say the irish republican army is
who did the irish republican army in the
south of ireland fight
it's northern ireland
[Music]
um
the last day of your life on mars i like
that okay the trip from france to spain
the irish republican army in the south
of ireland spent the last day of your
life on mars
um yeah
[Music]
and you just just looked exceptionally
young and i was just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tailgating an american football game in
florida tailgating an american football
game in florida okay
let's recap these and you may need to
remind me this is quite a lot
it's not this much the trip from france
into spain the irish republican army in
the south
of ireland was this one let's spend the
last day of your life on mars
yours was middle-aged women playing golf
a brazilian girls and tailgating an
american football game in florida
okay cool um yeah like i said you may
need to help me out on these ones but
this
is a little thing called a freestyle
wrap that's a wrap made up on the spot
based entirely on suggestions not
written
not prepared and i want you guys to
to not worry because it's not going to
be anywhere near
as atrociously embarrassingly bad as you
are expecting a proudly educated
middle-class white british boy to be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get so started toppings so many
things to spill
i pick up a t-bone and flip it on the
grill i make sure i baste it of course
never broil
fix it on the top with a dash a little
oil maybe vegetable
it's just me and my best mates we're
down in the orange state they're gonna
tailgate
oh it's really beautiful looks like a
tiny little scrotum i hit the turnpike
and i pull off there
in the stadium maybe we can never have a
day like this again
we're gathering round in crowds it's
amazing the teams
winning half of my mates ain't got the
vaccine i know they're smiling
over down there pick up a cause hold it
in the air
we get absolutely wrecked out of our
face and then we go in
and win winning in the footballing place
it's amazing
oh so damn ill i wanna go down south
america to brazil
ah it's so beautiful i got a glass on my
arm there she be dancing there on the
cover cabana beach
over in rio de janeiro take an oath i
will swear it to you we can hike the top
of sugarloaf
mountain that's the one with jesus the
redeemer christopher
yeah you should have seen her i so fat
like the number eight
you'll be doing pretty well yeah that's
my mate and when you ate
you're still looking so fine unlike the
middle-aged white women with the wine on
the golf course
do you wanna have some pinot grigio out
on the links yes
amazing that's your life goals squats
going here with the 18 holes
and if you hit it off the tee perfectly
it goes in the hole in one i sent for ye
i saved by the clubhouse a whole wound
the drinks all the white women in the
middle age they think their husbands
don't know about the secretive golf
trips but they know
they really want to visit sick and be
slick about this yeah
i understand why the army would be maybe
in northern ireland
how did they travel maybe do it by a
walk when they're down there
no battle no conflict really if you're
in the army you would hope that you were
picked for that
area to really go it's not hard let me
talk about this my last day
on mars oh man it's totally amazing it's
just me
and my buddy matt damon i say you've got
a potato
and he says you know the plot of the
martian and i'm partial
to the vet from idaho he'd be working
hard terraforming trying to grow
the little tuber from the ground and
then i say stop there
i'm really struggling my hoes not got
air it's been snipped by a martian guy
running up to me approaching me from
behind
i'm a little green man i'm the martian
i'm like oh no i struggle for air i
shouldn't trust
i cursed that bastard elon musk why did
you send me up here
to die on the planet last little thing
i'm walking across the granite and the
other little stones maybe igneous rocks
we're not
near the alps now that [ __ ] i really
stopped i'd be down over here now pay
attention please i'm basically here i'll
be chilling near knees now that's near
italy so i move far away
really wanna get my rocks off in spain
it's so beautiful
i've got a backpack to pull when i get
into spain i'm like check out that
[ __ ] the guy speared it that's a
torah with the fighter
moving from france to spain feeling all
right there so much language i've got on
display
i'm going to barcelona cause [ __ ]
marseille it's a great city
maybe i prefer going to madrid from
paris but either way i can't
because i must report we had brexit and
so i don't have a passport
[Applause]